Charles Spencer and his supporters can
argue perhaps that to be around head was
to be a defender of Freedom the
fundamental Rights of Man and popular
sovereignty he can and he did point to
the climatic years of the late
1640s which saw the round heads
challenge defeat and of course
ultimately execute Charles the first the
absolutist Tyrant as they would have it
as such uh child have problems because
we've got a nice and a nasty Charles or
you know two Charles's so Charles
Spencer uh of course can then argue that
with the Civil War we see the end of uh
what he's described as ridiculous
concepts of medieval kingship and the
birth of uh the Constitutional rule that
we take for granted today now I want to
sort of take apart some of those
arguments or at least challenge them a
little bit
I will argue that uh Charles Spencer's
support for the round head and indeed
his uh claims for their achievement
misrepresents their cause as it
developed during and immediately after
the Civil War
I will point to the reality of Life
under the rounds heads during the 1650s
and ask whether this was the kind of
country you would have wanted to have
lived in
we will look at the actions of the
archetypal and much praised by Charles
Spencer roundted Oliver Cromwell
has his achievement been overstated
should the round heads get the plaudits
that Charles claims they deserve
I will also question how decisive and
significant the Civil War actually was
in the journey towards constitutional
rule the victory of the round heads was
after all emphatically reversed with the
restoration of Charles II in 1660 and
one only needs to look for example to
the 1680s when the crown humbled
Parliament to argue that the round heads
did not inevitably set a course towards
constitutional monarchy
we also need to move Beyond these
stereotypical images of round heads and
Cavaliers as Jonathan said they were
born as terms of polemic and abuse
but in deciding your position today in
this debate it's important to realize
that this is not simply a choice between
a monarchy or Republic when we think of
round heads and Cavaliers we're thinking
more than that we're thinking about an
attitude to life a lifestyle a
temperament an ideal and it crosses
class lines
pleasure passion Joy devive or
self-control self-denial and a dour lack
of humor such is the Stark choice
now in reality of course we need both
but it's what you would prefer to be
made of the most if I can put it like
that that this debate is about but first
let us deal with the 17th century
context what was it to be a round head
or a Cavalier can we look back and make
a choice well it's not an easy question
everybody has an impression and mental
image of the Cavaliers gorgeously
dressed supporters of Charles the first
and of course we have Van Dyke to thank
for much of that the popular impression
has much to do uh with a Cavalier's
clothes and his Charles Spaniels as it
does with his politics and it's long
been a tendency to dismiss the Cavaliers
in the the words of seller and yatemen
in their 1066 and all that as wrong but
romantic as the unthinking unyielding
Defenders of an absolute this Monarch in
the face of those who asserted the
supremacy of parliament but actually
this is a crucial point that I would
First Take issue with uh nice Charles
here was that actually the terms are
much more complicated it's not simply
about forward against Divine Right
monarchy matters of religion of politics
geography gender family self-interest
all of these played a part in people's
decisions about which sides to take in
the Civil War
broadly speaking yes those who fought
for the king were high anglicans and
Catholics but they were there were also
some moderate Puritans there were men
and women and they were not simply
Defenders of a more rebound status quo
royalism was full of Vitality cultural
vibrancy and intellectual creativity
perhaps the archetypal Cavalier was the
king's nephew Prince Rupert who was put
in charge of the Cavalry he was tall
strikingly handsome and a brilliant
leader
he's often remembered today as little
more than being impulsive Cavalry man
brightly clad and Galloping at the head
of the royalist forces but actually that
does very uh scarce Justice to the whole
of the man when his participation in the
Civil War ended Rupert was only 26 years
old and went on to have an active Life
as a soldier a sportsman a scientist and
artist indeed our very own uh Charles
Spencer has written an excellent book on
Prince Rupert the last Cavalier and he
himself has acknowledged uh Prince
Rupert's appeal in this fantastic book
of Charles the the prince is portrayed
as impetuous and imperious but also
courageous and industrious a man
interested not only in The Art of War on
land and on sea but also an amateur
scientist who invented new arguments and
explosives uh sorry new armaments and
explosives an artist and a founded
member of Charles II's Royal Society
there was more to him than his handsome
looks and his spaniel wasn't there
Charles
another great Cavalier of course was
William Cavendish Markus and later Duke
of Newcastle in many cases he perfectly
matches the kind of stereotypical image
of the Cavaliers but again there's more
to him than this Beyond his enthusiasm
for fencing and horse riding he was an
important patron of the Arts in
particular Ben Johnson he wrote verse
and prose himself and together with his
brother he was at the Forefront of the
new philosophy in England promoting
theoretical research practical
experiments in Optics mathematics
mechanics and when he was in Exile he
continued his philosophical and
scientific researchers drawing Descartes
and Hobbes into his Circle he patronized
many of the leading exponents in the
fields of literature art music and
Science and he must be acknowledged for
this he also married whilst he was in
Exile and his wife uh who better known
as Margaret Cavanaugh dish was also a
figure much to be recommended she was a
feminist in many ways ahead of her time
the first woman in Britain to publish
books in her own name including a
biography of her husband
so I think we can agree that we can
dismiss the Cavalier stereotype of style
over substance uh I could go on I could
point to William davenon I could point
to Edward Hyde who wrote A a history of
uh the English I could go on uh not to
least to mention of course Cavalier
poets who wrote about sensual love and
the importance of enjoying life and
living in the moment
so from this distance it's perhaps
impossible to say whether where you
would have been in the 17th century a
Cavalier or a round head so many factors
were at stake and in fact again to add a
slightly more nuanced position to the
debate many people were initially
reluctant to commit themselves to one
side or another people saw themselves as
being both for the king and for
Parliament and were then only as the War
developed forced to take sides
and one of the round heads did they
prove to be the champions of popular
sovereignty and Liberty would you have
liked to live under round head rule
the round heads were against the
monarchy and in support of parliament we
know that but actually what's Central to
their uh belief was religion the
centrality of religion and we need to
put that very much at the heart of our
debate and we're talking about the round
heads here we're not simply talking
about a desire for simple Worship in the
face of Charles um more ornate uh more
ornate worship and equal access to the
scriptures we were actually talking
about their core belief being
predestination
in the Divine election for salvation of
a Chosen Few and it was this in fact
that galvanized their opposition to
church and King far from the Puritans
being egalitarians or proto-democrats
this was about the most elitist
worldview imaginable not to mention one
that tended towards astrident
paternalism and knowing what's best for
the unsaved and unwashed and we also can
see division in round head ranks after
the establishment of the Commonwealth
the group of thinkers known as the
levelers soon clashed with the newly
appointed Council of State key level of
leaders were imprisoned moreover many of
the tens of thousands of women who
fought on the side of the round heads
were equally disappointed when thousands
signed a petition for equal rights and
deliver it to Parliament they received
short shrift they were told by
cromwell's Parliament owners to go home
and wash the dishes pretty much much
worse to that effect when we're talking
about Cromwell and loyalty I think we
need to think in very different terms
than perhaps our nice trials here would
suggest what resulted after the
execution of the King was not the
Visionary Commonwealth that many held
out hope for in the end it seemed more
like a military coup than a democratic
Revolution England became a religious
Republic an armed Camp an occupied
country in all but name where law might
easily be delivered at the point of a
sword as in the magistrates Court
along with this massive security
campaign was this drive to puritanize
the land the Church of England was
destroyed uh Bishop priests chaplins
School teachers were ordered to leave
their posts the universities were purged
all joy was removed from daily life
Christmas for goodness sake was to be
banned even on a Sunday no longer could
you do horse riding or knitting
Cromwell we need to consider very
carefully he he displayed a colossal
self-righteousness a course intolerance
uh and for bullying he was no Pro to
Democrat he of course perpetuated in
Ireland not least Infamous atrocities
which dominated uh that period and he's
appalling cruelty is acknowledged right
to this day and of course in 1653 this
great Champion defender of parliament
dissolved the Rob Parliament and in
doing so he undid a stroke the entire
legitimacy of the war which he'd fought
against the king's own on parliamentary
principles the Republic failed have I
got one minute
I haven't pinged yet oh I haven't pinned
oh good at least oh brilliant the
Republic failed in 1660 there was a
widespread desire to establish the
relationship between crown and
Parliament
and with the restoration of Charles II
the exploits of the parliamentarians
were emphatically reversed
so much that in 1700 the Laureate John
Dryden could write thy Wars brought
nothing about
indeed it might be argued that the most
important effect of the registered and
cromwell's protectorate was to induce as
one historian as describes an enduring
mistrust of radical institutional change
in England if Charles the first had not
been executed it might be us would we
still have a monarchy now
but what about the terms roundhead or
Cavalier today and this is really where
the heart of tonight's debate lies these
terms survive regardless of the 17th
century conflict and have come to
describe different and opposing types of
archetypes in British national character
and just as in the 1640s it's not simply
a question of class or money left or
right but it's one of taste and
temperament on the one side we have
flamboyant the love of fun a scorn for
rules a sense of irony on the other side
we have those marked by earnestness
discipline in life and work and Iron
Will to give up pleasure always ready to
be outraged or indignant ready to wave a
finger of disapproval and not naturally
given to irony and some people might say
isn't that basically American culture
well in many ways
in many ways that's true many of the
English revolutionaries were exported
there at the restoration
Cavaliers instead rely on flamboyant
connections they rely on the big picture
big gestures taking risks seizing the
day they believe in self-sacrifice if
the chords motivates them they celebrate
the court Cult of the amateur it's about
taking part not necessarily winning
now in their commitment to hard work and
moral property of course the round heads
are to be admired they've made a
considerable contribution to Britain
today they've set up bureaucracy and
systems with ebola hatted
professionalism
but are we now not increasingly aware of
the dangers and the downside of
roundhead Britain an encroaching sense
of the nanny state of being told what we
can and cannot do there's grown
resistance to the intrusion of the state
to health and safety regulations Big
Brother surveillance cameras in our life
yes we've achieved thank you round heads
but at what cost Society is now
suffering from a burnout an inability to
get off life's treadmill a sense that
there's more to life than work but not
knowing how to change we all want a bit
more Cavalier influence in our lives we
all want more food more good company an
appreciation of the better things we can
also I think see Cavalier and round head
types among politicians I'm sure we
recognize roundhead ones rather
humorless puritanical dour more focused
on winning and being more politically
correct than inciting the passions you
know the type of people it doesn't make
you want to stay watching question time
they are the politicians who conform to
professional party machines who follow
the dictats of party officials or Spin
Doctors Cavalier politicians on the
other hand stand out for their
irreverence their passions their
determination not to be politically
correct one might have Carol Tony Ben as
a figure might one might even point to
Boris Johnson you don't have to agree
with his politics to acknowledge his
flamboyance and his ability to liven up
a debate surely Winston Churchill with
his glass-smoking love of Rogues he's
Relentless passion he's charm and wit
heralded by many as the greatest britons
was the ultimate Cavalier
nowadays surely we want more Cavalier
politicians there's too many clones too
many risk-averse carbon copy MPS who
have few core convictions for which they
are prepared to live and die for
political disaffection and disengagement
is surely a consequence
oh what Ed miliband would do for some
Cavalier charisma
and so to return to the motion ladies
and gentlemen life is short life is
precious we should celebrate it and
enjoy its riches and live in the moment
ladies and gentlemen do I look like a
round head I urge you to reject the
motion and support me in saying I would
rather be a Cavalier than a roundhead